find at Fort Lauderdale Hollywood
International Airport we hate to beak it
to you here all right dude that's enough
stopping a firearm in your holiday bird
for travel is just a base of time
Anthony please don't make me keep doing
that good Lord that is that is okay it's
pretty stretchy back there this is a
this is a cry for help
[Music]
welcome back to all and Dave nobody
nobody says nobody's clams you just
gotta believe in yourself and say it
hard hey what's up y'all like that part
that was a good one that's a sharp
shooter thank you no go back to school
but I did want to bring in this topic
because I know that we're experts when
it comes to things like this okay
ovulation
expert yeah Joe is the sex person the
number one sex bird uh a Florida
traveler stuffed a gun into a raw
chicken and tried to bring it on the
plane a raw chicken like a whole chicken
photo and one of my favorite Parts is uh
tsa's response via Instagram with a [__]
ton of puns I mean dude the raw
chicken's like the biggest giveaway what
the [__] are you bringing the raw
chicken on the platform I know because
they won't even let you do that a gun is
more normal yeah you hide it it's
something else you can't bring yeah what
the [__] that's really funny
what happened oh they found the gun that
I hid in the bomb yeah it's like they
were trying to think about like what
this is the size I can give to you right
now that's the raw chicken yeah you can
see the [__] whole thing oh my God
there's a little baggie in there the
trigger is exposed do they think that
the chicken would hide it in the X-ray
so you wouldn't see it it's so good he's
like don't you see a skeleton that'll be
fine does it remind you of those like
like those 90s movies where the Hitman
is like a butcher in a shop and he has
the gun in the chicken and then right at
the last second he just pulls it out so
good maybe that's who he's trying to the
butcher's so paranoid
that guy's not a butcher it did work
well in Terminator when he had a [__]
shotgun in a rose box oh that was false
that's fire remember I was shooting he
was flicking it special delivery you
guys ever see Hot Fuzz yeah yeah but I
forgot everybody in that whole village
had the shotgun with the roses and like
butcher shotgun
yeah or uh or or the flute that's a gun
A gun in the guitar case what movie was
that um
Desperado no that shit's cool was that
Antonio Banderas sure was so TSA post
red flag is it's a rotisserie chicken I
know already cooked that's normal it's
like oh he's gonna eat on the floor oh
he went to Ralph's just bringing it back
that does make more sense good deal raw
chicken's weird when we came back do you
think this guy like bought the raw
chicken and made a conscious choice to
say this is what we're gonna do or they
just happen to have it and they're just
like I mean what items can we hide this
gun in I guess the chicken yeah maybe it
was desperate
Desperado Desperado yeah for sure I
think it's utility I think he's like I
don't want to eat or old rotisserie
chicken so I'll wait and then oh I'll
have a chicken and I can put my gun
inside of it and then I can cook it when
I get to my destination it's a twofer is
that a carry-on yeah or is that like a
check bag it's a curio carry on put on
Spirit on Spirit you might have to pay
65 seeing somebody's carry-on being a
raw chicken you know how they trick you
at Spirit So when you buy the ticket
right they're like would you like to
purchase a personal item or a carry-on
or whatever right and they have a
picture of a backpack so if you're
traveling with a backpack you think you
have to pay that extra 20 bucks but you
don't because you get one personal item
free and the backpack couch is a
personal item even on Spirit yes but
they try to trick you with that image of
a backpack thinking you have to pay for
them it just has to fit in the overhead
you won't be able to fit uh three
tracksuits well we all know Spirits
sucks so you shouldn't fold them that
many times
much [__] because it's fifteen dollars
for a flight to Vegas so I mean like but
you know what you can
fit they'll probably let you do that
especially if you crunch the bones so
they're malleable the thing that I don't
understand is you don't have to smuggle
a gun like you could just
put it on your check check in like you
could just put it in your check-in and
and you don't have to or maybe maybe
that's what they said you could just put
in your check-in he's like oh you put in
a chicken
that's actually good that was actually
good here it is
I got one I got one I I I usually like
[__] you Anthony that was really good
that was really good chicken that's my
favorite one so far sometimes when you
do puns it makes me want to actually
like go kill myself but then this one I
was like wow this is chicken in the
chicken yeah kill yourself a little bit
yeah a little Pang of like oh it's time
for it he was inevitable here's a lot
more puns this is how I go TSA takes
these photos and posts it online on
their Instagram and they put a lot of
puns in this yeah I'm gonna have Steve
read them okay so this is their IG
comment this is their IG comment
favorite form of Comedy this already
hurts there's a personal foul here
the plot chickens as we Barrel our glad
you left closer to Thanksgiving because
honestly keep going okay for us it's a
time to be thankful that our officers
are always working around the cluck to
keep you safe take for instance this I
hate these can you believe it find at
Fort Lauderdale Hollywood International
Airport we hate to beak it to you here
all right dude that's enough stopping a
firearm in your holiday bird for travel
is just a base of time Anthony please
don't make me keep doing this that's my
favorite one the base the time that's
good Lord that is that is a taste of
time okay it's pretty stretchy back
there this is a this is a cry for help
that's I think Elon should delete these
this account Elon should have something
in there about puns afterwards like it's
a danger warning you know the sword is
Terrorism first of all guys Elon owns
Twitter this is Instagram whatever dude
I need a trigger warning before they do
pun jokes like that yeah because
Anthony's poem was really good I you
know what this has been a historic
moment how did none of them think of
what you thought of that's pretty
because they work for TSA they're not
for for JK news yeah dude it was either
or either go right into TSA or JK news
after college right he has been writing
the captions yeah that's true
TSA worker though like we have TSA fans
right and like we have TSA we have a lot
of tsas yeah we do I'm not kidding
because they'll call they'll call you
out but the thing is um you know how TSA
can be busy sometimes so like when I was
going through I was like yo man my bag
is there I haven't been able to grab
anybody to check my bag in like 20
minutes and then a fan comes out and he
goes Joe and I'm like yeah he goes I got
you and he left his post and he [__]
did his thing for me and I'm like thank
God I'm not gonna miss my flight now has
this ever happened to you so last night
I didn't do a lift and uh the guys like
Steve Green and I'm like yeah and he's
my he's my Lyft driver right and then I
get in the car and then like I'm
expecting to talk to this cat right
doesn't say a word after that
so it's like you go from being like Okay
so this guy's like you know a fan or
whatever and it's like oh no he just
knows me it's like oh no the reviews are
in
it's like this guy knows me but he's not
saying [__] it's like this guy maybe
hates me at home or maybe he just read
the name on the app Steve Green all
right cool come in the app doesn't have
my name it's crypto King yeah I'm
crippling on that I'm Iceman on there
no but I was like I was like oh [__]
like
I think this guy [__] hates me
yeah the reviews are in yeah he's all
we're gonna take a little more Scenic
around
I'm gonna take you through all my
childhood memories of you yeah yeah you
never know
does that ever happened to you guys so
that was it was it yeah that was it no
but I was expecting yeah I know what
you're talking about because you think
like normally if they say that they
follow up with oh so how's Nikki what's
up how's Nikki yeah how's Timothy D and
[__] like whatever but when they don't
say anything and then afterwards in most
cases when I ask them like oh uh
whatever they go I don't you know I know
how you don't like like fans bothering
so I didn't want to be too rude oh
that's kind of cool yeah because we
always they gotta say it for it to be
cool because we're always roasting how
weird fans are like the weird ones right
because we you know when we did our
grand opening and all that people were
just like hey I know like I really want
a picture but you don't like that and
I'm like what are you talking about I'm
talking about the [__] most socially
awkward [__] weirdos normally
everybody's chill well you're talking
about people who are like sneaking
photos instead of just coming up and be
like let's get a picture yeah like the
people that are just
they overstay their well like they're
just extreme cases hey they're like over
here and they're not even talking to
JJ's Cafe yeah yeah like really weird
cases and they're like oh I don't want
to be like one of those people you talk
about and I'm like no like I like this I
like the normal thing yeah of course
yeah the normal ones yeah please come up
and say what's up if someone's kind of
worried about how they're gonna make
their impression they're probably fine
they're probably like even if you're
thinking like that you're probably good
if you already think about that then
that means that you're considerate yeah
I don't care I've always had it's always
been I've always had Pleasant times
always I love the idea of you going in a
lift and then the guy saying Steve Green
and then just driving it that's what
happened every now and then you see his
eyes look at the mirror like that's
[__] crazy dude oh it just puts you
in your head because you're like wait
does he know me from the app but then
I'm like look in the app and I'm like it
just says Steve like it just says Steve
so I'm like this is weird when you're
wearing your wound necklace I'm wearing
all my wooed out I'm [__] glued from
head to toe now I'm just wearing like
normal normal Steve [__] like I'm
wearing a Colts jersey I don't know man
I don't even see normal Steve [__]
anymore because every single time I see
you in photos even in Vegas with random
people with Nikki and stuff you're still
fully you're rebranded because the
rebrand's on I told you
you go Outdoors like that I do yeah it's
because in Vegas it doesn't matter
can walk around like that in Vegas tell
you bro the one time I regretted it was
the hottest summer I was like God damn
what am I doing and then I look at
myself in the Miranda I'm like it's kind
of worth it but I'm like oh man it's so
[__] hot on these things remember
there was a actual guy in Vegas wearing
that outfit but it was like all Versace
or something yeah well there's a lot of
those guys it's a look it's a whole
thing it's a Vegas thing there's a
movement but mine's like the Costco
version it's funny you saw those guys on
the strip and you're like that's the
next look yeah no that's it that's what
I'm gonna do yeah it's basically Vegas
yeah yeah but like Ellis Island Vegas
thank you yeah I kind of want to do the
real one yeah the real what the Versace
one I like Versace out of all the brands
that's like pretentious right that's a
little bit like uh what's wrong with
that where it's like I can't afford it
right now no I know but when I get there
yeah when you get there but then bumper
pay first but then do it yeah okay yeah
because that would be kind of a dick
it's like how did he get there that
should be fun maybe I should cut their
pay again
so I want to do it oh you know sorry
guys you guys I know how I can allocate
the funds
I come in with Versace that'd be so good
thank you Steve for this inspiration we
needed to do something for myself
honestly um I would love it if you wore
tracksuits but then and then cut your
pace I would love it
you know me I would actually cut your
face like afford it I would actually I
would always respect the joke always but
you know that [__] is Thousands like
it's a lot dude they're crazy I was
gonna get one that was Dolce Gabbana and
it was like [__] three grand I'm like
take as much as you [__] need bro I
was like I spent two grand two wool
hoodies I'm a [__] and I got a 25 000
Dragon I should calm down a little bit
000 and a tea Dragon yeah this is lit
it's also a money pit but we'll find out
money hey at least it's on uh the Juno
blockchain you guys ever heard of it
nope
[Laughter]
upgraded dude to a new chain there's 15
users on it thanks a lot levona team
we're gonna [__] die in the cold I
see what you mean
I never even got my egg back I know I
know I didn't have the heart to tell you
I know it's okay I'll give you one I'll
give you one we'll research the genome I
have plenty of eggs trust me they're
worth eight dollars laughs
[Music]